you're never too young to be a BMW fan
the German carmaker attracts people of
all ages each year some 3 million flock
to BMW Welt in Munich to see the latest
models like the new m4 coupe a with a
starting price of over 70,000 euros
in the premium lounge buyers can even
pick up their car themselves a
consultant is there to assist the
customer and see to it that everything
runs smoothly it's designed to be a
personalized experience sort of
experience really is important and
experience that's tailored to the
individual client that's my job as a
customer service rep to really see the
person in front of me yes Tito Lumia tie
cha has come specially from Southern
California
he loves the sound of the m4s engine
stand in the center turret stereo for
sure
this is a reason why this is
this is the reason why
it's all about power and status if
you're driving a BMW you're always like
they say have exhibit as a success like
you know as far as the person is
concerned so I want to exhibit you know
the fact that I've been very successful
and so that's why I've chosen BMW as
well the assembly plant is located right
next to BMW velt
Marcus Heinrich is a regular customer
the management consultant is picking up
his ninth BMW he's brought his family
along and booked a factory tour it's
really exciting to see how complex it is
to build a car like this close to 500
parts go into the body alone it's
exciting to see how smoothly it all
comes together the finished product
costs over 70 thousand euros but at
times like this money is seemingly no
object just perfect the feeling of
freedom it's great we're celebrating the
car I know it'll never look this lovely
again
Tai Chow has brought his parents along
for the ride
BMW enticed us customers to come and
pick up their car in Munich by offering
them a five percent discount
Tai Joe used the money he saved for the
trip to Germany and plans to see what
else Bavaria has to offer beyond BMW
vote